[Music]
oh damn we are really in a deep hit you
know we can never return
we need to go dive deeper to eventually
find a bright light
[Music]
military coupe is the biggest thing ever
that we hated so i think i'm pretty sure
people will get on the streets
[Applause]
[Music]
that's
[Laughter]
[Music]
i still have nightmares and i still have
a lot of different guilty survival guilt
as we remember because my friends are
being killed my friends are
now in prison torture
[Music]
i see the stage sort of set for a
belonged conflict neither side
seems willing to back down or sees it in
an interest or out of a necessity to
back down
they do feel abandoned by western
democracies by the international human
rights movement by the international
media by everyone
[Music]
if we keep on doing this resistant in
the right way with rightful ideologies
we will get there people power will
prevail in the end we'll eventually make
sure there will be no more dictators and
no more crew in the country